uh let me ask you the ridiculous
question uh
i don't know if you have an answer but
who is the greatest chess player of all
time
in your view so since you like chess
talk on how you define it but if you're
talking about raw skill
like if you put everyone across time
into a tournament together
yeah um carlson would win i don't think
that's particularly controversial oh you
mean like with the same exact skill
level
exactly magnus costume because the
object now if you talk about
political importance i think bobby
fischer
is uh you know he's a he's the only one
that people still
we used to go to someone on the street
they know bobby fischer because he was
because of what he represented
right who do you think is more famous on
the street
uh gary casparov or bobby fischer
probably fit in america
but if you think so yes that's
interesting i think we're gonna have to
put that to the test
yeah maybe it's maybe it's more
reflective of the community that i was a
part of but yeah
oh so in the community you're a part of
like young minds playing chess
bobby fischer was the superstar in terms
of like yeah
i think so because he's american and
you know he stood up against the big bad
russians yes at the time
and uh you know unfortunately he had a
very bad downfall
but um what you know for our
geopolitical situation
he meant a lot and then if you talk
about compared to contemporaries
actually i would say paul murphy was a
bit of a throwback
was he's one of those geniuses that uh
was just head and shoulders above
everyone else
is there somebody that inspired your own
play like as a young mind
yeah i really like mikhail tall so like
you see you were
i think he was very aggressive right
yeah very tactical yeah
um which is funny because i am i found
that i was better at like sort of slow
methodical play
than quick tactics but i just i mean
there's something beautiful about the
creativity
and that's something i always latched on
to was being a creative player being a
creative person
i mean chess doesn't really reward
creativity as much as a lot of other
things especially entrepreneurial
pursuits
which i think is part of the reason why
i sort of grew out of it
but i always was attracted to the
creativity that i did see in chess
you